what's going on guys this is Rob and
Magneto fights Iron Man so this kind of
kicks off with this idea of Iron Man
sort of musing to himself right I can
feel the fillings in my teeth Rattle and
I know it's on and then even Magneto
makes this common to himself right he's
like this one's arrogant and Reckless
even for a human but in my experience
he's no fool because obviously Magneto
knows who irman is and he says surely he
would not dare attack me of all mutants
in a simple suit of iron if he has this
will be a very short battle indeed so
the first question asked here is why are
Magneto and Iron Man fighting in the
first place well it's the week of
Christmas and we're doing some pretty
interesting videos that are relatively
simple and this comes out of Avengers
versus X-men the long and short of that
story is that basically there was a
mutant named Hope Summers the first
mutant born after the events of House of
M and she basically represented the
return to the mutant population that in
and of itself is not a bad thing she was
going to become the host of The Phoenix
Force which is terrifying because the
last time that happened we got the dark
Phoenix Saga so the Avengers went to the
X-Men and said give us hope the X-Men
said no she's one of us and a fight
broke out between them inside the main
story is this the versus series and so
it's basically different Avengers
fighting different X-Men which is what
we'll cover over the course of this week
so the thing Iron Man says in response
to this is like my power courses through
his armor and I have my answer he isn't
wearing metal and so in turn with
Magneto thinking about Iron Man fighting
him in a metal suit he uses his powers
to really just kind of test right like
what kind of suit does this guy have and
his power courses through his armor and
that's when Magneto gets his answer that
Ironman is not wearing a metal suit he's
wearing a suit composed of carbon Nano
tubes now without understanding the
context yes itd be very easy to say okay
so like Iron Man's got some kind of
McGuffin but the thing to know is that
Tony Stark is a future he's always
looking to the Horizon so of course he's
going to have a suit that's not composed
of metal if he ever had to fight Magneto
but the other thing about this is that
with the Avengers going to fight the
X-Men Iron Man would have to be prepared
for something like this right because
Magneto is a longstanding member of the
mutant community and so that's literally
where he's just like I'm sorry if you
thought this fight would be over by now
then we must not have met and he's like
my name's Tony Stark you may know me
from such things as routinely using my
amazing intellect and unparalleled
resourcefulness to save the entire world
and that's where the fight breaks out
because Iron Man to a degree
underestimates Magneto yes he's able to
overcome Magneto's ability to control
metal because he's not wearing a metal
suit and he even fires his Repulsor
blast but that's what Magneto literally
just kind of says so your armor isn't
metal oh dear however shall I possibly
defend myself it's like a scene out of
X-Men the Animated Series if you guys
remember that when the Sentinels
attacked Magneto on the tanker and he
used his powers on them and they're like
this version of Sentinel is not made
from metal it's made from like hard
polymer Plastics things like that and
Magneto is like we're on a metal tanker
this whole thing is my weapon because
the world uses metal really more than
any other element I would imagine I
would think I don't know if that's a
true statement or not but they're
surrounded by it and so in effect they
are in a just gladiatorial battle arena
metaphorically speaking where every
object is Magneto's weapon and the best
that Iron Man can do is kind of Bob and
weave now the thing about this is that
again as most of you guys know Magneto
is able to use his control over the
electromagnetic spectrum to create force
fields around himself and it's one of
the first things that Iron Man realizes
is that his Repulsor Rays cannot get
through this force field he doesn't
really vocalize it in fact he will he in
a second but what he does do is he
actually ends up creating or at least
kind of dispelling these sort of devices
and in fact it's basically his anti-
magnetism Arsenal right it's activated
firing super magnet swarm this suit of
armor is by all standards of measurement
a Magneto Buster suit it's designed
explicitly to deal with Magneto and
nothing else and for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with the Iron Man
Buster suits that's what they're
designed for right Hulkbuster thorbuster
godbuster Magneto Buster they're all
designed for the purpose of being able
to overcome a particular person and even
Magneto comments on this right like
Stark has so many toys things so Cutting
Edge I barely understand the ones he had
5 years ago let alone now his resources
are without limit all I have is a
tarnished helmet and an old man's heart
one forged in the fires of the Warsaw
Ghetto for many years now that has been
enough to get me by I will expect today
will be no different now that's kind of
the thing about Magneto right and this
is one of the cool things about it right
Magneto really kind of just Roots
himself in the struggles of the past and
that is enough to help him overcome a
variety of different adversaries out
there in the world but as you guys will
see towards the end of this the fight is
not going to go the way you think it
will and in fact I don't think any of
you guys are going to guess right in
terms of How It Ends but Magneto kind of
comments to himself right I count 2
million Neo denum highgrade magnets
these must have cost you quite a pretty
penny and the thing about Iron Man using
his Repulsor way is and even using this
is It's a way to kind of shut down
Magneto's ability to manipulate the
electromagnetic spe within this
immediate vicinity but there's only so
many and seemingly the way they work is
they have to be in relatively close
proximity in order to operate in any
real effective way so it's not as though
he can just kind of space them 50 feet
apart and create just this gigantic
field that nullifies the powers of
Magneto it would be cool if he did but
seemingly he hasn't been able to do that
now whether or not Magneto is able to
overcome these magnets isn't explicitly
made clear contextually it seems to be
the case but if the purpose behind these
really are to shut down his powers
they're not necessarily working but even
in the conversation they have Magneto
goes so far as to kind of make the
comment right the guards who hurted us
into those camps in World War II always
said that they were following orders
right the famous line that everybody
kind of heard from the nberg trials and
he says when this is over will that be
your excuse as well will you be a person
who says I was just following orders I
was just doing what I was told but even
Iron Man kind of fires back and it's
like well let's not forget your past
right like you were one of the World's
Most Wanted men until you handed
yourself over back in the old trial of
Magneto's storyline and then he
ultimately became leader of the X-Men
and the New Mutants but the idea is that
Magneto is a guy where depending on how
you look at it he's every bit as
villainous as the people that he fought
and there's even a story in Uncanny
X-Men issue number 150 where Magneto
almost kills Kitty pride and because
Kitty pride is Jewish he comes to this
realization that he's every bit as the
oppressors that he experienced from
Germany during World War II it was
actually the reason why he handed
himself over to the world court or at
least one of the reasons because it was
him kind of repenting for his ways but
at the end of the day Iron Man does kind
of clap back with that whole point but
Magneto much like people on Reddit just
kind of dismisses the point and then
focuses on what he wants to focus on and
so what he realizes here is he says my
plan number onea proved a smashing
success assuming my goal was to leave
him brimming with well-deserved
confidence what say we skip ahead to
plan 180 Z and that's when he fires up
the Jupiter one right now this is kind
of like a satellite that exists out
there but what it does is with this
satellite orbiting Jupiter it allows
Tony Stark to channel the
electromagnetic spectrum from Jupiter
into the satellite and then through a
daisy chain of satellites back down to
earth and he says the magnetic field of
Jupiter is 10 times that of Earth I
should know I spent some nights there
what can I say some ladies have kinky
requests cuz you know it's Iron Man but
he says all it takes are a few
well-placed satellites to siphon off
some of that energy and send it my way
and then suddenly there's a whole new
master of magnetism in town and he's
able to basically enhance his own
Repulsor rays and then do some damage
and blow through Magneto's force fields
so it's not really him manipulating
magnetism it's really him just blasting
through Magneto's Shields but in Magneto
realizing this even he himself bolsters
up his own abilities and in fact he
literally just kind of grabs pieces of
what's around him and then fashion it
into a more durable suit of armor one
that can go toe-to-toe directly with
Tony Stark's Iron Man suit and this is a
really really cool adaptation because
now we're basically dealing with you
know Magneto's Iron Man Buster armor if
you want to call it that but it's pretty
solid because as these guys are going
back and forth and as they're fighting
one another it really just kind of comes
down to good old plain hand to-hand
combat and by most all standards of
measure me Magneto is more capable than
Tony Stark when it comes to fist
fighting right just one guy against
another this is not to say that Magneto
is like some prodigious fighter he's
pretty capable and in fact he can use
his control over magnetism to boost his
own abilities and allow him to go
toe-to-toe with people that he wouldn't
necessarily go toe-to-toe with but the
kicker about all this is in a moment
Magneto's distracted and that's what
gives Iron Man the upper hand now this
distraction comes in the form of
Magneto's realization that the Phoenix
force is much closer than they think it
is and that he literally tells Iron Man
you have to go find the Scarlet Witch go
find my daughter she's the only one
that'll be able to Stave off the power
of really Hope Summers with the power of
the Phoenix because there's one thing to
keep in mind while we won't really cover
Hope Summers over the course of this
week one thing I do want to mention she
was a mutant that had the ability to
duplicate the powers of anybody around
her with no upper limit and to hold an
infinite number of powers and then you
bolster that with the abilities of the
Phoenix Force she's astronomically
powerful and so with this distraction
Iron Man knocks out Magneto Iron Man
incapacitates Magneto and then Iron Man
takes off back into the main conflict
itself with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end let me
know how you guys feel about this right
it's pretty dope and who do you think
would actually win and I will catch you
all later peace